on this friday night
picking up the pieces the impact of that
tornado in barrie ontario
it was in and out before the warning
arrived stunned residents take stock of
what they lost and
how much worse it could have been
europe's devastating deluge
catastrophic flooding sweeps through
five countries leaving more than 100
dead and hundreds missing plus welcoming
the fully vast
how soon could double-dosed americans
and other foreigners be allowed
to visit canada the devil of course is
in the details
and changing tides how a wobble in the
moon's orbit
could be a cause for concern in coastal
areas
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
you never fully realize the power of a
tornado until it hits
this is the aftermath in barrie ontario
at least 25
families have lost their homes or had
them badly damaged
environment canada says it was an ef2
tornado with wind speeds
up to 210 kilometers an hour
good evening and thanks for joining us
it hit with very little warning and
though several people were injured
no one was killed and that is the one
big relief
as the community comes together to clean
up mike draulie is in
berry and has our top story tonight
the five kids in yulia berkovic's
daycare saw it first
kids were screaming like no no no birds
what's going on to birds because they
thought it's birds but it wasn't the
birds it was part of a roof
their eagle eyes might have saved their
lives for berkovic instinct took over
and she hurried them into the basement
seconds before the tornado hit her house
and then i realized when i came out i'm
like doors open
no roof and then i looked up and then i
got scared
her car was flipped over the roof in
smithereens
across the street natalie harris emerged
from her own house
stunned by what she saw
oh my god oh my god
oh my god the roof is gone minutes later
she was in the street urging
yulia to get to safety come outside
yeah your house is falling in come
outside with winds topping out at 210
kilometers per hour the tornado has been
classified as a high-end ef-2
considering its size climatologist dave
phillips says
there were remarkably few warning signs
so often the sky can be
black you just know there's green shade
to this you just know that something
wild and wacky is going to happen but
there wasn't really that ominous kind of
look
the city of berry is no stranger to
tornadoes one of the largest in canadian
history an ef4
with winds over 330 kilometers per hour
killed eight people and damaged a large
portion of the city in 1985.
living on the northern edge of ontario's
tornado alley
residents know the threat is real but
reality is still a shock
for all the jagged nerves a day later
there's a lot of relief being felt here
lisa lansbury's two children were in
their rooms in the front of the house
the tornado skipped over the back
because if it had been coming
this way our house would have looked
like those houses across the street
and my kids would have been in the room
so so you missed it by
the width of the street yes
[Music]
sorry i'm just very emotional the
tornado created a massive amount of
damage along its five kilometer long
path
but despite all the destruction you see
here household items are among the most
dangerous items in a tornado
one man we spoke with found his chainsaw
dug deep into his back long
after had been sucked up and swirled
around by these strong winds
and donna 11 people were treated in
hospital here
but considering how fast this tornado
moved in most people feel
they got off lucky back to you
i'm sure they do mike gerlay and barry
thank you
another disaster is unfolding in europe
torrential rain triggered devastating
flooding there more than 125 people are
known to have died
hundreds are still missing it was the
heaviest rainfall in a century
three months of worth of rain fell in
just 24 hours in some places
in germany entire towns were submerged
roads and railways
washed out in the netherlands a breach
in a dike forced thousands to flee
a major worry in a country that is
mostly at or
below sea level the relentless heavy
rain began
wednesday causing the catastrophic
flooding across western europe
from germany the netherlands and belgium
to luxembourg and into switzerland
the intensity and scale of it has
shocked some climate scientists who have
long warned about extreme weather
as crystal demancing reports rescuers
are still scrambling to reach remote
villages
roads houses shops the flood waters
spared nothing german officials call
this a flood disaster
of historic dimensions
there wasn't any more left that could be
broken he says half the village
is destroyed more than 20 cities and
districts in western germany are
battling back the waters
power has been knocked out to more than
100 thousand households
and mobile networks have collapsed in
some flood regions
making it nearly impossible for families
to check on loved ones
as the raging water grows deadlier at
least
1300 people are still unaccounted for
emergency officials are working around
the clock
dramatic rescues taking place off
rooftops and in areas
devastated by the flooding the german
military has been called in to provide
support several key dams are sitting at
critical
levels the rushing water a spectacular
and concerning site to take in
a breach would push the situation from
bad
to worse in neighboring belgium people
in the east
and south are being urged to stay home
and off the roads
swollen rivers and flash floods have
also turned deadly here
we've had to go through renovations says
this man we've had to live through covid
we're hoping to get back on our feet and
there you go
flooding has washed out large parts of
the rail network in southern belgium
high-speed train service to germany is
suspended
as impacts are felt across northern
europe
the full extent of the damage throughout
the region won't be known
until the water recedes but the number
of
deaths is expected to rise
crystal gomanson global news london
in this country the bc coroner's service
has now updated the number of people who
died during last month's record-breaking
heat wave
it now says there were 808 sudden deaths
reported between june 25th and july 1st
it's not clear how many were related to
the heat
but it is about quadruple what's been
reported during that same
time period over the past five years
more than 300 wildfires are still
burning across bc
close to 3 000 people have been forced
to flee their homes
and many residents say they're
frustrated the bc government has not
declared a provincial state of emergency
one of the most aggressive fires is
burning near 100-mile house
that's where paul johnson is tonight
paul
donna here's a daunting thought to
ponder there are roughly five
times as many wildfires burning in the
province of bc
right now than we would normally expect
for this time of year
of the dozens that are burning just in
the southern half of the province
the bulk of the evacuations that have
been triggered by those fires
are in the area of hundred mile house so
far
there are 1500 properties that have
received an evacuation order
now one area is the south shore of canon
lake and that's a popular
and well-known destination for people
with cabins and recreational properties
now residents there and we spent some
time with them this afternoon
have been dealing with this stubborn
fire for about
two weeks now watching it shift along
the mountain
and in some cases inching down the
mountain towards some of their homes
you can only imagine how nerve-wracking
that must be
this fire just keeps on going it just it
instead of
like it was almost under control
then they left alone and it went right
under control again
so and now it's reaching right across an
entire mountain
it just keeps going and going and going
and it doesn't seem like they can stop
it so
now the town of hundred mile itself is
under evacuation
alert that means the 2000 odd people who
live there
have been told to pack their bags and be
ready to leave
on a moment's notice if that alert turns
into
an order of course the big picture here
in british columbia is this
has all been driven by the weather that
record-breaking heat wave that we saw
here a couple of weeks ago
combined with persistently dry
conditions what we've heard
there's likely to be a break with some
rain hitting the northern half of the
province
so far the forecast isn't offering
anything
meaningful that could help these fires
that are in the southern half of bc
donna okay paul johnson near 100 mile
house
thanks smoke from wildfires is affecting
millions of canadians a heavy haze is
blanketing calgary and an air quality
statement has been issued for much of
alberta
those most at risk are children seniors
and people with cardiovascular or lung
disease
alberta is still very hot and dealing
with its own wildfires
90 are burning right now 14 are out of
control
and more than 130 wildfires are burning
across saskatchewan driven by windy
weather
and hot dry conditions the air quality
index
is at very high risk through the central
and northern parts of that province
this is a look at the smoke shrouding
the saskatoon skyline
people are advised to avoid strenuous
activity
outdoors now to the pandemic canada is
making progress keeping case counts down
and vaccinations
up more than half of eligible canadians
now have had both
doses and the prime minister is now
hinting the border could
open to fully vaccinated people from
other countries
by early september abigail beeman looks
at what's being planned
and what factors it hinges on
it was an absolute source of of
heartbreak that they missed
his entire baby hood mirae leijae is a
canadian living in the us
and there's been no help for families
like hers to reunite with grandparents
with two boys too young to be vaccinated
and therefore forced to quarantine
this is very frustrating you know my
husband and i were both vaccinated the
entire community where we are we're all
immunized
the code rates are extremely low while
all 50 states
are seeing an increase in covit cases
blanket border rules are baffling many
we are looking closely at what the next
step
would be particularly when it comes to
fully vaccinated
or fully vaccinated american neighbors
and that is a conversation which is
happening
in close collaboration with the leaders
of the provinces the government now
signaling it will open the border to
fully vaccinated americans in mid-august
and fully vaccinated travelers from
everywhere else by early september
the prime minister and premiers
discussed the plan thursday night
including concerns border services will
have enough resources to process
a surge it's that type of collaboration
i think that
the prime minister is welcoming i
certainly are prepared to
offer and i believe the major provinces
are as well there are many details yet
to be announced including the mechanics
around an international vaccine passport
even if there isn't an overall plan
let's make sure there's a plan to
implement
this announcement because at the end of
the day policy without execution
is just policy it's not it's not action
that i think is key because it will
build confidence the current border
closures expire
wednesday the prime minister is
promising more details next week
canada and the u.s have so far moved in
lockstep the white house says the
president will soon be briefed on the
latest in terms of reopening
but one white house source tells global
news there's nothing yet on the american
side that matches what our prime
minister
is saying abigail beeman global news
ottawa
ontario has moved to step three of its
kovid 19 reopening plan
for the first time in months indoor
dining gyms cinemas nightclubs
and other venues can reopen there are
still capacity limits that nearly all
businesses and masks will still be
required
social gatherings of 100 people are
allowed outdoors and
25 people indoors about half the
population of ontario more than seven
and a half million people have now
received both doses
of a covid19 vaccine bringing
back the masks a cautionary tale from
the us
coming up restrictions return as
americans battle what's being called a
pandemic
of the unvaccinated plus a monumental
moment
in paris
the remains of a third canadian have
been pulled from the rubble of that
collapsed condo in florida
global affairs canada has confirmed the
person is canadian
eight people including one other
canadian are still unaccounted for
recovery efforts may soon come to an end
three weeks after the surfside building
collapsed
97 people are known to have died
germany has declared greece and the
netherlands coveted risk zones again
because of a sharp rise in cases today
the netherlands reported more than 11
000 new cases that's the biggest one-day
increase since christmas
just two weeks ago restrictions were
lifted in the netherlands
the uk is also dealing with a huge surge
there were more than 50
000 new cases today plans are still
going ahead to drop the remaining public
health restrictions
on monday both the uk and the
netherlands are cautionary tales about
relaxing the restrictions too soon and
in the us
los angeles is reimposing its mask
mandate
for everyone regardless of vaccination
status the restriction was lifted only a
month ago
but the highly transmissible delta
variant has led to a rapid and sustained
spike in cases
in every single state and as jackson
proskow reports hospitalizations are
rising fast too
almost exclusively among the
unvaccinated
it took less than a month for los
angeles to go from success story to
cautionary tale
with the delta variant surging rapidly a
masked mandate is coming back
this daily increase in cases so the high
level
where we are now puts us in the category
of substantial community transmission
all 50 states are now seeing an increase
in cases a surge
driven by the unvaccinated i don't like
it i'm vaccinated
i wish everybody else would get
vaccinated so it's a little frustrating
in las vegas masks are once again
recommended for everyone
in mississippi those over age 65 the
most vulnerable
are being told to avoid gatherings
indoors regardless of vaccination status
this is becoming a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
99 percent of hospitalizations and
deaths are among those who've avoided
inoculation
in areas with low rates of vaccination
the virus is surging fastest
breakthrough cases though typically mild
are being reported in larger numbers
among the fully vaccinated too
our vaccines work they work for what
they were intended to work they prevent
us from dying prevent us from being in
the hospital
in a country with easy access to
vaccines there's still substantial
reluctance
only 48 percent of the population is
fully vaccinated
the white house blames an epidemic of
misinformation
circulating on social media and
conservative cable news channels
there's no reason right now no clinical
reason to go get vaccinated
those who peddle and promote these
dangerous lies
are harming the very people who are most
at risk
and furthering a pandemic that has
already taken more than
six hundred thousand american lives
more will surely follow amidst the
renewed surge in cases
hospitals are filling up again and
deaths have started to increase
many of the states now suffering the
hardest claimed victory over the
pandemic long ago
making the return of widespread
restrictions or lockdowns unlikely
instead americans are told they face a
stark choice in the face of the delta
variant
get vaccinated or risk getting the virus
donna jackson proskow in washington
thank you
the eiffel tower in paris has reopened
after an eight-month closure
are still mandatory elevators will run
at half capacity and visitors
will have to show either proof of
vaccination or a negative test
this was the longest closure of the
eiffel tower since the second world war
still ahead the great beluga migration a
whale of a time in canada's northern
waters
here is a stunning whale's eye view
these belugas are making their way to
hudson's bay
more than 57 000 of them swim from the
arctic to manitoba's churchill river
basin each summer
that's about two-thirds of the world's
beluga population
and you can watch their travels live on
the beluga whale
live cam set up by a conservation group
to study
the arctic ecosystem
well taking a selfie took a painful turn
for three british siblings
lightning hit them right as they snapped
the picture
it happened while the jobson siblings
rachel andrew and isabelle
you can just see them there under the
flames
they were out on a rainy bike ride in
london isabel has a titanium plate in
her arm which the siblings suspect may
have attracted the lightning
all three of them were fine they were
treated in the hospital for minor
injuries and discharged
a few hours later with quite the picture
to tell a story
watching the moon wobble next why people
in coastal communities need to keep an
eye on the shifting lunar orbit
the flooding in europe is another sign
of the extreme weather events that will
happen more often because of climate
change
and now nasa is warning about a natural
wobble in the moon's orbit
it will lead to higher tides and
combined with climate change and rising
sea levels that relatively small shift
in the moon
could have a big impact on coastal
communities here on earth
mike armstrong explains
it's not a sort of flooding brought on
by rain or spring runoff in fact it can
happen on a sunny day
they're sometimes called a king tide
coastal areas are flooded by a
particularly bad
or high high tide well nasa's sea level
change
science team says coastal communities
have a problem
basically just around the corner king
tides that are even higher and
happen more and more often instead of
something that's almost a curiosity a
rare occurrence like when this king tide
hit la jolla california
it could be something that happens often
the reason
the moon it's getting closer it's
getting a little farther away
jess mcivers with ubc's department of
physics and astronomy
she says we don't really notice
everything the moon's doing
it's not just orbiting earth it's
wobbling sort of shifting and tilting as
it goes
it's also changing its orbit in a cycle
that lasts 18.6 years
well at one point in that cycle its
gravitational pull on earth means
higher tides it's nothing new the
phenomenon was discovered in 1728
the difference is climate change it
happens to be coming in conjunction with
sea level rise
what that'll mean is when the cycle
starts to amplify the tides in the mid
2030s there's going to be a bigger
impact than ever there will be more
coastal floods
and they'll hit in clusters they could
come back day after day for a month
or even longer yeah they give us
glimpses into the future
case lachman is the director of ubc's
coastal adaptation lab
he says sea levels are rising and
there'll be a major problem decades from
now
but the surge from the king tides he
says will give us an early look at what
higher levels will mean the king tides
are just a peek into
the future of what a 2015 normal
situation might look like right now
nasa says urban planners on the coasts
tend to worry about extreme events
hurricanes and storms
they're also going to have to prepare
for more high tides
like armstrong global news and that is
global national for this friday i'm
donna friesen
tonight's your canada is this
picturesque scene in the cypress hills
near maple creek saskatchewan
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again on tuesday take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]